大変お待たせいたしました始める秋をイラストブドウからぴょくん
4こちら外れ社長ですそういうわけでを沸かせいたしました
1ヶ月ちょっと前にですね皆さんにお願いしたいことがありますと午後を出させて
いただきましてみなさんにフリー素材こちらを渡して芸術的な画像を作っていただき
たいということでツイッターで皆さんに募集していただいたところとっても沢山の芸術
的なイラスト画像写真を皆さん作って頂きまし
あざをつくってくださった皆様本当にありがとうございました
ほんとで全部紹介したいんですけどもうちょっとそういうわけにもいかないので今回
その中でですね多くによりすぐりだったものをですね皆さんと一緒に見ていければいい
なと思っておりますまあ良いよ冬なんでねほんとにもう秋の最後
的な芸術作品を共に見て秋を締めくくりましょうではいい
学校にっぽんどもゆるっと見ていきますからね1番目こちらですフェアと一高すごい
すごいすごい
素晴らしいですねやっぱあの子のイラストの使い道としてバーありげに座らせたりする
ことって結構しやすいと思うんですけどもそれをこのようにですねあのラテアートとし
て組み込むの発想力素晴らしいと思いますと言いますありがとうございますどうぞ見て
きま
卒業こちらあたげな申請を阻止する初めこそ新たをもちろん
じゃないです
をこのぼーっとした顔をしておきながらも人を困らせるというその姿勢にすごい芸術的
な何かを感じました本当にありがとうございますそれで3番目こちらどうせも座って
いるように見えず初めにでテトリス略して畑に据え凄い凄い羽鳥しても呪文素晴らしい
ですね
座ってるんですけども支持的なちょっとまっすぐに美人で負けてるのブロックに
見せかけたという画像になっております
次の3つも始めホールドしているのも始めたなぁこれを落としても規制なそうそれでは
こちら
爆弾を仕込んだちょっとあったんですねこれが俺だな
ターゲットよりも僕が危ないですそれでこちら肇社長と卵とああいい感じにキングで
当てはまってますねそれでこちらはじめを買うはじめ
よく見たら俺が入ってるのは合成師
5校かぼくっていうその2つの家計に技術を感じましたありがとうございますそれで
こちら今日はねだから滑り込みに提供するだけで作りました q
スええええ俺待って白が全部俺出てきた目
てるんだね東西努力賞ですねそれではこちら
霧生はじめ口周りの関係図まず俺が言って遊びですカードれ大親友の俺
はじめと親友付き合いたてでも俺はないかい続いてこちら色鉛筆で書きましたえええ
ええ
ウソでしょ8僕ねまず a 予防集合
おにゃん
かつすぎて申し訳ない動い城へペースで書いたんか
すげーなーもう純正に感動しました今何か
ですすいませんこちら新しいクレーターが発見されたもよああ
ねじ込んだねつぎこちらですね簡単にですああなぜ穴
筋肉痛で払いたいんじゃね簡単に食べられてるはずるんですねこれは溢れかえってます
ねさん匹釣れたこちら端リザ
5000枚ですね全然こちらロケット派がすげーぴったりきてじゃあこれやポップで
良い方だと思いますありがとうございます続いてこちらはじめだけのはずなのによく
見ると
女の人が見えてくるような気もしなくもない9枠でこれなんかみんながをなれが見えて
くるようで気がしちゃうんだけどねっ
そうでもないわ次
えええこれ全部俺じゃあ髪の毛も女も始めも
機
[拍手]
痴漢とってごめんな続いてこちらですいやもう俺の素材とかじゃなくて
イラッハウスバスで初めてジャケットを着る外れるなんで素敵な抱くと書き方なん
でしょ
ところでも可愛いし実はよく見るとで右上の方にで真面目と書いてあってもすごい
しっくり作り方になるんですよね
きてすぎコップのハチコ
シークレットでタイマー子なんだろうなあコレなんで悪魔を塗りつぶして呈しつつある
んだ次ぎ延期のビザやふわっとるやないかいなく座ってからペンキ塗りただに気づいて
落ち込んでる顔が浮かんでますねそれはぼくのわたしたイラストとてもマッチって
素晴らしいと思いましたありがとうございます次初めにより始めのタイプ
すごい早大なぁ俺と君の初め
もう道具あった d がことだけ始まるはじめ深いようで朝五ツギ
歴史坂本根元対応してる感じて声出てるんですがね騎士っていうのがまた戦争を感じ
ますねちゃっぷはず学習帳です次
らしき世界大会決勝戦で大事な試合中にお腹をクラス何もかもどうでもよくなって
しまった肇社長
ほんとがみんな一生懸命やってるのに俺だけやる気がないお
ちゃんと言ってほしいです次東海のフライヤーが完成したので応されてください多い
なぁ
動い何度目指しに使えそうですねこれ入居企業広告を見ること生々しいつまりくらいや
作ってくださったんですねありがとうございますに全社会に急ぐワークスコア
れじゃないに人がはじめ今度行ってみようから次注い集めて言ったらあんだ俺の
イラストはイラストでにあるいや次何か
強そうな始めるんですよロケット弾で一番偉い人なんだろうなぁ
次って公演は独占するはずねすぐ溶けてください次
そこじゃないよ
すごいなものにが画像すら外でその随員当然面白くしてくるの素敵ですねつぎ肇社長が
週間ブースに取り上げられている外れちゃう会社で出会った彼女と方や公認同棲中
サイズ感なあーすぎさしぶりに一さんの動画見たらこんなたり商談会参加させて
いただきます中国雑ですが書かせていただきました塗りロボットに乗せかで船長へ
駆り出される生物園駅
クローンを始めたい方ボールでしょうかお納めくださいすごい俺嫌だったんだろうなぁ
全部の機体に乗ってる僕が全部嫌そうな顔してるんでまあすごいいやいやロボットに
乗せられて潜在向かっている
時間しますねつぎはんだよねではないだろう
なんであんなんだか打ってよああとやる気出して
ぴば夜中てるひとつが外れ雪を作りましたうわーもう細すぎてわかんな
ぜひ考えでないけど販売レビュー1考えとるは次
楽しく流そう雑すぎるけどなんでさオーレの首とった
いきます実はデジ
林の壁開放に参加せた本当だちゃんといるはもうちょっとやる気出す厚木市ごと割に
本屋さんで買いました読むの楽しみ値下げも白根パネル社長の裏側冊を稼ぐ近いてるん
だろうなぁ
次初めはここまでがはっきり3人に現れ取り上げ
もうちょっと僕逃げる石田してほしい顔してますね11時に参加させられたはじめ
みんないい映画をなのに俺だけやる気が
ないあんとやる気を出しましょう次人類は思い出した彼らに支配されていた京子
うじゅるってゆールールってすごい出てきてるなーずに目覚めできず氏は見せない
あっ減るのをやめたはず3冊をこれやだねたしかにこうなりますね
次金白は負けじゃなくてはじめを背負っているんだよ
たりですね夕霧はじめの規律パソコンで肇社長
ああああああ
これも全部俺だぁの下俺だし身も俺だぁ7分俺だし次はじめけんたんを
ザッツだけどしっかり作りこんでてをもそれで次仲間にでしかっはじめ
ね顔にはすわー変えるといっしょなんだろうなやっぱりこういうの結構好きですよね
ぜひ始めよう着物百人乗っても大丈夫
よく102起きましたねこちらー大気圏突入
をはじめあった
燃え盛っているし僕の表情を曇らせているのがあえてそんな顔してるのかなっていうの
を思い出させる感じがしております地上2月頃にはどうなっているのでしょうか
次方針やのはじめみんな待ってますねつぎはじめ一体化 a うるくらーいたはいい
感じでビーチに待ってましたごめんくださいありがとうございます次襟足を伸ばして僕
を g にしてますね
怖いです次
8近くで作りましたをワイヤーでもよく頑張りましたねありがとうございます次は
売り上げがしたねー
むりりんぐだしたねこれこれの里車れますいやもう狂気を感じて俺の画像でピッチを
作ったで動いけど
ございます最後のピース
4日
右ですねすごいよこんなの作るで10億みたら kermit 謎とフォルザなんとと
かあるんでしょこれフェア理由もあるしね風邪はどこから
ベンザブロックいろんなの掛け合って凄いって言うのはパネルには入りたくないです次
和美社長たい場所を買いました白亜紀に行ってきます
ああああ通わせんで移動して失敗したんでしょうね僕のスーツだけが残ってますよく昼
クラス会でいい飲み物だけ飲んで帰る別の俺
乗ってください次行ってバーディフィニッシュ
柿安前提きーさんの頭に思いっきりスマッシュが入ってましたねどうぞよい
ファイトいう感じでございました本当にまだまだのいいのがたくさんあったんですけど
も
ちょうど70枚近くはあの発表させていただきました
感覚で作ってくださっているものもあったりしてすごい楽しかったでまたこういう機会
があったらぜひ皆さんさんがしてみてください開いてくださった皆様ありがとうござい
ました
じゃあ
[音楽]